all right the browns moving forward
without odo beckham jr here are baker
mayfield the team's quarterback and
kevin stefanski the browns head coach
talking about what it means to not have
odell beckham jr for the balance of the
season here they are
there's this theory kicking around that
you know baker might be better off
without odell
why is that a flawed argument
well one i think it's just completely
insensitive to a guy that just tours acl
so i'm not even going to comment on it
you never want to lose guys and that's
that's where i'm gonna leave that one
could there be a lessening of the
pressure on
um baker if that's the right word to get
the ball to number 13.
tom i really don't think so you know
again odell is a great great player
we're going to miss him
i feel sick still without him
in the building but
our offense is based on 11 guys and the
quarterback going through his reads and
it was like that with 13 in there and
it'll be like that without 13 in there
it sounds like the same voice asking the
questions of both people and very
different tone why is it a flawed
argument well it's not a flawed argument
that baker mayfield may be better
without without otto beckham jr and i
don't think it's disrespectful to have
that conversation you take away the guy
who constantly is the subject of the
conversation about is he getting the
football when's he getting the football
why isn't he getting the football get
him the football you take that out of
the equation and you just let baker
mayfield throw to the guy who's open
without this extra baggage and
distraction of force feeding the ball to
a guy who may be covered who may be
deliberately taken away by the opposing
team's game plan defensively that's not
an appropriate question it's not a
flawed argument and look at how mayfield
played last week without beckham on the
field
he was over five in the first quarter
mike with that first first pass
interception that got odell hurt they
went 22 for 23. the one missed was a
spike ball he absolutely played better
without a ldl beckham in the lineup and
we're going to find out long term
because they're not going to have o'dell
the rest of the season if they are a
better offense and on top of what you
said i'm going to add this it allows
them to run the ball which is what
they're best at they're 18th in total
offense but they're third in rushing
they're going to get nick chubb back
they have kareem hut they can run the
football and they run the football very
very well as good as any team in the nfl
we've talked about that one two-headed
monster it is a one-two punch at running
back they can commit to the run they
don't have to worry about getting odell
his targets look he was first in targets
with 43 but he was second in catches
they don't have to worry about that
anymore i think they're going to be a
better offense and i think when we look
back at the statistics late in the
season
baker mayfield's passing i think we're
going to see he's a better quarterback
without odell and then it puts them in a
quandary
with hi with odell coming back off that
acl what do we do about odell
well no o'dell next year if they make it
to the playoffs without him and i think
that it was appropriate for mayfield and
sofanski to say what they said but i
hardly believe it's inappropriate for
people like us to say you know what
browns and mayfield may be better off
without that you know and it's it's cost
benefit
yeah you lose the talented player but
you also gain
the absence of that narrative that just
has weighed the team down for the last
year and a half
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports